We will now talk about
hierarchical clustering,
the last clustering approach we
will discuss in this lecture.
In practice,
clusters often have subclusters.
These subclusters often have
other subclusters,
and we want to capture
the stratification of clusters.
For example, in this case,
these are two clusters,
but they can be split further
into more and more clusters.
To capture this stratification,
biologists construct trees where
every leaf corresponds to a data point.
Every horizontal line crossing this
tree will result in a set of clusters.
For example, this line crossing the tree
at four points will result in four clusters,
while the line crossing the tree at six
points will correspond to six clusters.
To construct hierarchical clustering
trees, biologists first transform Data, an
n x m expression matrix, into an n x n
similarity matrix or distance matrix.
For example, they can construct
the distance matrix by simply computing
the Euclidean distances between
the points in the data set.
As soon as this matrix is constructed,
the hierarchical clustering algorithm
starts from just representing all data
points as leaves in a tree
that is to be constructed.
Afterward, the hierarchical
clustering algorithm finds
the smallest distance
in the distance matrix.
In this case, it finds that this
distance is realized as the distance
between the third point and
the fifth point in the data set,
and it connects the corresponding leaves
and forms a new node that is
a parent of these two leaves.
Then, afterwards, it merges these
leaves into a single row of the matrix,
and in the newly constructed matrix
(I will describe later
how the distances in this newly
constructed matrix are computed),
it once again finds the shortest distance.
In this case, the shortest distance
is realized between
element two and element four,
and they are also connected to
a parent node by edges.
I will define later how to define
distances from this parent node to
the leaves.
Once again, it collapses
leaves two and four
into a single node in the tree and
re-computes the matrix again.
In the newly constructed matrix,
it once again finds the smallest element
and continues in this way until
the whole tree is constructed.
In other words, when there is
only a single cluster,
which corresponds to
the root of the tree, left.
Here is the pseudocode for
constructing a tree from a distance matrix
that pretty much follows the
algorithm that I just described,
specifying some details on how to
compute the distances in the tree.
The only thing that remains
unaddressed in this pseudocode
is how to compute the distance
between the newly-formed clusters and
the remaining clusters in the current
partition of the tree into clusters.
And there are different
approaches to clustering.
For example, one can compute clusters
using average distance between elements
of two clusters or by using minimum
distance between elements of two clusters.
Of course, this may result in
different clustering problems.
These are six clusters built
by HierachicalClustering for
the same yeast dataset that we looked at
when we talked about k-means clustering.
These clusters are often a departing point
for biologists to decode
difficult regulatory puzzles.
For example,
if you look at the first data set,
you will see that there is a
sudden surge of expression
at the last checkpoint for
genes in this data set.
When biologists started looking
more carefully at these genes,
they saw that upstream regions of
many genes in this cluster contained
the "carbon source response element" (CSRE)
with the motif shown on this slide.
And by noticing this, they started
to decode the biological puzzle
of yeast being able to switch from
the glucose to ethanol pathway to
the ethanol metabolizing pathway.
Indeed, since yeast prefers glucose
over ethanol as an energy source,
genes responsible for
metabolizing less tasty ethanols
are repressed in the presence of glucose.
So this carbon source
response element helped
biologists to decode the puzzle of CSRE.
Indeed, it turned out that CSRE
activates the genes when
the yeast runs out of glucose and
starts consuming ethanol.
I think we are done
with the diauxic shift.
Phillip, should we try
this bottle of wine?
>> Sure, I think so.
Thank you.
Our students may think that
we do it after every class.
>> Well, we actually do, don't we.
>> Actually Pavel, come to think of it,
>> you mentioned cancer at the beginning.
>> What happened with that discussion?
Back to recording.
In this lecture,
we focused on the diauxic shift
rather than medical applications
of expression arrays.
In fact, expression arrays have both hopes
and concerns when it comes to oncology.
For example, gene expression
studies reveals that breast cancer
has more grades than previously thought,
and as a result, there is a possibility
to add a genomic grade
to a traditional histological
classification of breast cancer.
On the other hand, microarrays allow
doctors to distinguish between
morphologically identical
types of leukemia and
lead to a better clinical outcome.
However, there are also concerns about
applications of expression arrays
in clinical oncology.
First, tumor sample
preparation is critical for
accuracy and reproducibility
of expression arrays,
and standard procedures for tumor sampling
or storage are still in development.
Very important, the bioinformatics model for
classifying tumors should be extremely
accurate if bioinformaticians want them
to be applicable to medical applications.
Indeed, they should have
extremely low false positive and
false negative rates because false
positives lead to unnecessary surgeries,
while false negatives lead to
missing early stages of cancer.